masks have become part of the pandemic
wardrobe
some even opting to wear them outdoors
but in just over two weeks time the
legal requirement to wear them in some
confined spaces
is likely to be dropped with the
government instead leaving them to
personal choice i think i
will like pretty easy to do
and it stops the spread yeah like of
course why wouldn't i it's like it's
still existing it's not going to go away
by
july 19th or whatever it is i mean you
see mass compliance is already
relatively low now so i think this will
just drop further
i'm quite happy wearing one and um
and you know i'm just i'm just gonna do
it so i
i will know when i want to give it
myself the one meter plus rule is also
likely to go
on july the 19th in a move that will be
welcomed by pubs and restaurants
that currently have a cap on the number
of customers limiting their income
the housing minister told sky news it's
time life returned to
normal and he'll get rid of his mask i i
don't
particularly want to wear a mask i don't
think
a lot of people uh enjoy doing it
we will be moving into a phase though
where these will be matters of personal
choice
and so some member society will want to
do so
for perfectly legitimate reasons but it
will be a different
period where we as private citizens
make these judgments rather than the
government telling you what to do
studies suggest mandatory masks reduce
the rate of the viruses spread by around
12 percent
so making them voluntary will increase
cases but the vaccine is keeping down
deaths
giving the government some leeway
scientists are divided over the ditching
of face masks
some argue it's better to learn to live
with the virus now rather than waiting
until the winter when the nhs is busy
with other respiratory infections
but others say covet is like driving the
rules are there for
everyone's safety and making them
optional will lead to a car crash
choice only works if it's properly
informed said one scientist on the
government's covet behavior committee
this meme around personal responsibility
is
is a bit of a red herring because of
course
um when it comes to any risk management
behavior
it's everybody's responsibility and that
includes the government
and the idea has seems to be being
floated that the government can abdicate
its responsibility is of course nonsense
in scotland the government has said face
masks will still be required in shops
and on public transport even
after other restrictions are rolled back
in august but in england the measures
that have ruled our lives for the last
15 months
look certain to be lifted in a matter of
days
thomas more sky news in oxford